i can just tell you the news
massachusetts governor deploys national
guard to drive buses
all right there's the story 250 members
of the national guard are being
deployed to support and assist local
communities in their school transport
efforts there's there's there's two
things i see in this story one
yo they're starting to deploy national
guard
to like do infrastructure work
that's crazy the second thing is
aside from the fact that it's sort of
you know it's like a military move to
support the crumbling infrastructure
uh our economy is on fire i don't know
about you guys in the uk i know it's
pretty bad i guess
you were telling me a story about you
couldn't even it was like really
difficult to even travel here but seeing
this story just says to me like
everything we've seen over the past few
months with food shortages labor
shortages
this is the this is bad
i suspect it's going to get
substantially i just saw butcher said
that beef prices were going to be up
like two bucks by next week two bucks a
pound maybe or something by next week
yeah there was a well there was a period
where it doubled
beef there was like one week where beef
was double the price
great reset what are we doing what's
happening man i i it's so weird man
we're living in the strangest time
period and
what's crazy is that all of us who were
able to foresee some of these second
third and fourth order consequences
were
labeled all sorts of names right so from
the beginning of this whole pandemic
situation going way back
i was far more concerned about the
response and the downstream
repercussions of that response
economically financially people's health
people missing diagnoses of other
diseases people's mental well-being
depression suicide effect on children
all of this stuff whole bunch of things
i haven't even mentioned
it was obvious right i mean if you
remember back to say about 14 15 months
ago people were acting like it was some
toss-up between saving lives and saving
the economy when people were talking
about the economy they were saying oh
you know you want people to die you
don't care about grandma you're putting
money above people that's what people
are saying because they don't understand
that the economy is the people if people
aren't working
then
there's repercussions of that in my
country like the nhs it was all safe the
nhs saved the nhs almost like how do you
think the nhs is funded if people aren't
working then you're not saving the nhs
you're actually going to eventually
bankrupt it
and it's already in it was already in a
tight position before all this but the
thing is when people are gripped by fear
they lose their ability to think
logically and rationally elon musk
tweeted that meme where it was like an
astronaut on the moon and a comet rips
through the earth blowing it up and then
he's like oh no the economy or something
like that there were a bunch of people
who were posting dinosaurs looking up at
the you know the meteor coming down and
they were like oh no the economy and i'm
just like i see this stuff and i'm like
man
it's like you said the people who can
see down the road who have who can see
the second third fourth you know fifth
layer consequences to this are telling
them like dude
you have no idea what's in store and
even right now you know we're hearing a
story about the national guard being
deployed well what does it mean when the
government starts deploying military to
handle infrastructure
you get dangerously close
to such infrastructure damage that
martial law is a real potential as a
real possibility i i would i kind of
like it though in that i think that our
national guard and our military should
be used to build the world that would be
nice instead of destroy it for once like
if we could build solar power water
condensation on housing all around you
know decentralized so in a way we did
that in afghanistan come on we gotta
build this force you know just through
like where it's wanted where it's needed
where where people need drinking water i
i i hear what you're saying but
i i i recognize it if they were like hey
we've got a national guard and we're
going to do like fixing this road and
you know fixing the pipes in flint and
maybe helping build new houses in middle
america but this issue is our
infrastructure is crippled to the point
where they're like if we don't have
people working
use military like
i'm i'm not gonna pretend like this
guarantees we're headed towards
communist dictatorship or something but
when you get to the point where your
military is being used for critical
infrastructure if that continues and
more jobs are lost which is happening
and more nurses are quitting more
doctors are quitting how long until
they're like oh they've already deployed
national guard for hospitals yeah
there's how long until they're like okay
plumbing how long until they're like the
the critical infrastructure of this
country is being run by the military
there's a big difference between using
the military to do good and having no
choice but to use the military because
that's a deep spiral that could get out
of control what's the what's the proper
role of the national guard i'm familiar
with the term but i don't know what what
is exactly is its role supposed to be
look it up well so we uh national guard
provide it's a simple way to put it
state army i know that's probably
offensive to maybe a lot of national
guardsmen but each state has their own
national guard they provide defense for
the country they provide support they're
deployed in riots and things like that
uh they're not supposed to it's my
understanding i could be wrong with this
because i was not in the national guard
in the military so you guys might know
better they're not supposed to enforce
laws necessarily but provide support
internally whereas the the army the navy
the marines mostly external defense of
this nation they can't enforce laws
internally so
this says here during peace time each uh
this is from military.com each state
national guard answers the leadership in
the 50 states three territories in
district of columbia during national
emergencies however the president
reserves the right to mobilize the
national guard putting them in federal
duty status yeah so uh we see them
deployed for riots pretty often
floods natural disasters they come out
and they provide that critical support
in major disasters so i think it's fair
to say that we're looking at an economic
disaster right now
my concern is this is not a disaster
that ends you know hurricane comes in
hurricane leaves you got to fix
everything national guard can come and
provide a security and assistance and
it's awesome
this disaster is being exacerbated yes
the the mandates are expanding they're
getting worse the economy has taken a
hit now now biden's got his national
vaccine mandate i don't know if you've
heard this in the u.s 100 employees or
more people are going to quit like crazy
but the thing is it's it's a
manufactured crisis exactly it's
manufactured when i say that i'm not
specifically saying that the
virus is manufactured but the response
to the virus
none of this stuff is necessary
right it's not it's not necessary
especially at this point right where
it's september 2021 now we're not even
talking february or march 2020 at this
point where you've got the majority of
the population have already got immunity
not just in the usa but in lots of other
countries cdc study said 80
yeah and they're still just going
further and further i mean you know if
you create these mandates there's going
to be job losses like that's just
that's obvious so i know with a lot of
people
people don't like to assume bad
intention and people like to assume that
politicians and the media so on and so
forth are always working in the best
interests of the people
but at this point i personally cannot
put this down to incompetence i haven't
been able to probably for about a year
but certainly at this stage i'm like man
there has to be
malicious intent there because it
doesn't make sense to me otherwise maybe
right you know because
you mentioned hanlon's razer before the
show as well we can sit down never
attribute to malice that which can be
explained by incompetence but there's
something other than malus or
incompetence there's banality yep you
know so we often is you know uh dumb or
diabolical i think you know who jack
murphy jack murphy
diabolical and uh
well what about
indifferent
what about you have a governor who's
sitting there and he's like
all right so we got kova deaths
i don't want to take responsibility for
this
shut it down it is easier for a
politician to say
shut everything down
so that they can be like see nobody died
yeah and then when people are like
you're damaging the economy he can be
like pandemic don't look at me
if he says reopen like they do in texas
and florida what happens the media says
oh all those dead people are your fault
your fault so you have politicians who
are just
it's the end it's it's the it's the
fecklessness it's the i don't want to be
responsible so if i lock everything down
you can't blame me for the lockdown you
can blame the pandemic but if somebody
dies then they're going to blame me for
not locking down yeah i would i would
consider that incompetence
that i suppose yeah i'd call that
incompetence because if you are a leader
you're part of your job is to is to lead
and to make decisions and to have
principles and to to stand on them so if
you're not willing to do that then
you're not a competent you're not
competent in that
yes fair point if you're incapable of
assuming
uh the responsibility of the office then
you are incompetent what if you're
unwilling
then you shouldn't be there same same
value there like so so is that malicious
i guess my question no no i mean i think
malicious had means you know you you
mean to cause some type of harm or pain
or suffering
um but incompetence i mean incompetence
doesn't
it can mean stupidity but it can also
simply mean what it what it says right
you're not competent at this particular
test there are things that i'm
incompetent at right i'm i'm an
incompetent ice skater
right there i'm an incompetent
skateboarder right like i don't i don't
know how to scam i have no competency in
skateboarding i saw you miss a few of
those shots yeah
i walked down and you like missed and i
was like oh
he's got no skill
so yeah so incompetence doesn't
necessarily mean i think some people
think it means like
stupidity
or
but it's really more a lack of ability
in a particular thing you could also
have malicious people that are
incompetent oh you can have both
they're not mutually exclusive
they're not mutually exclusive oh dude
but the way if you look around the world
and you you see the way things are
marching in lockstep
like how that can't be accidental right
how how is it that
all these different countries i mean
look at the commonwealth countries how
is it all these different countries
are doing things which
literally prior to last year were
totally unthinkable the cons whether
even from from a simple lockdown to
something as simple as a mask like this
is unprecedented when was there ever a
mask mandate when was there ever like
lockdown was just prison terminology
right like we've had diseases we've had
vaccines we've had all these things our
entire lives but all of a sudden it's
this and it's that and it's that and all
these different countries are doing the
same thing there's a couple things i'll
say that are you familiar with the
concept of a standalone complex no i'm
not so a conspiracy a group of people
coordinate the effort then take action
and then you'd see a bunch of banks get
robbed and you're like what is this
conspiracy a standalone complex would be
say you know 50 banks get robbed in
every state at the same time and you're
like this must be planned and
coordinated but a standalone complex
means that each individual took
independent action that just coincided
with other similar actions creating the
appearance of a conspiracy which can be
exacerbated by copycat crimes and things
so if one especially with social media
if one person makes a bad move and a
government all the other governments are
american oh yeah there's definitely a
lot of that going i mean i don't know if
you guys know that the uk was initially
going to take the sweden approach
throughout this whole thing yeah right
that was the initial plan for the uk
yeah so boris johnson was not the uk was
never supposed to have lockdowns and
mass mandates all of that
and then specifically there was a lot of
pressure from certain people in the
media
put on boris johnson and then if you
remember he himself got hospitalized
with kobe so he got shook and he saw
that was when he when he flipped he came
out of hospital and then he started
singing a different tune let me let me
say one more thing too and then in the
countries all doing the same thing
if you take away someone's knowledge of
freedom
then they won't understand what freedom
is they won't you know i'll give you a
chicken example right so we got these
baby chickens
i gave it a stink bug and they just
stare at it all confused and i'm like yo
your chickens eat the stink book but
they don't know no one's taught them
right
so when all of these countries do the
same thing it's because they've they sit
there and they watch one country do
something and then go do what they did
so you know often when it comes to
chickens
i'll throw in some some food object
they've never seen before and the seven
outside will come and look at it and
then one will eat it and as soon as they
do everyone then is like okay i can eat
this yes so
probably a better example is business as
we're growing timcast.com and hiring
more people we're running into these
bureaucratic problems and we're running
into just general issues with running a
business and then it turns out the
solutions are exactly what the
infrastructure has provided like why are
there services that provide hr services
it's like oh because we encountered this
issue
and that's why all the businesses do
things this way
so i don't necessarily think it's a
conspiracy or anything like that or not
to imply that you were saying it was but
to see all these countries doing the
same thing i think it's two things one
they have no idea what they're doing so
they're simply like i don't know do what
they did and then the other thing is you
know
well i guess that's basically it right
if if they can't perceive of how to deal
with this
then they just absolve themselves
of responsibility do what everyone has
done elsewhere because then they can act
like they're doing something because
you'll often hear from many on the left
saying well we can't do nothing when in
reality nothing is often the right thing
to do absolutely yeah absolutely i think
people have forgotten that an
overreaction can be just as bad or even
more deadly than an underreaction or no
reaction at all and i've been screaming
for a long time that
the the uh consequences
of the response are more severe than the
consequences of
the initial threat i still maintain that
position i don't know exactly how you'd
be able to calculate the total harm and
deaths caused by all this but
these things have long-term
repercussions i mean if you remember
back to the financial crisis in 2008
there's still repercussions from what
happened 13
years ago that that's what happened and
it's it's very it would be
extraordinarily hard to quantify the
amount of harm and pain and
problems that have come from that um but
i think this is the same thing i think
literally 10 years from now you're still
going to have
issues which originated again not
because of the virus itself but because
of the response to it whether or not
that is
intentional
or that is a matter of incompetence or
some combination
i got people to decide thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you